احتجاجات وايران مستمره في اسبوعها الثامن
ومجموعات كبيره من المواطنين تسير على خطى
الاحتجاج والاضراب واشنطن بوست سلطت الضوء
في تقرير لها على المعاناه التي يمر بها
الاطباء في ايران خلال التظاهرات المنتشره
في البلاد الصحيفه اشارت الى ان الاطباء
كانوا من بين اوائل المشككين في التفسير
الرسمي لمقتل ماسا ميني في منتصف سبتمبر
عندما تحدثوا عن تعرضها لردود وقصور قبل
وفاتها منذ الايام الاولى للاحتجاجات
تمركزات قوته الامن داخل المستشفيات
للتعرف على المتظاهرين واعتقالهم كما ضغطت
على الطاقه الطبيه للابلاغي عنهم لاحقا
ومع تزايد الاعتقالات بدا العديد من
المتظاهرين بتجنب المستشفيات ما دفع
الاطباء الى تقديم الرعايه داخل المنازل
معرضين سلامتهم ووظائفهم للخطر ومن لم
يستطع توجه الى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لنشر مقاطع مصوره حول كيفيه تنظيف الجروح
وتضمي والتعامل مع الاصابات الاخضر
كالجروح الناتجه عن طلقات ناريه او طعنت
العاملون في القطاع الطبي لم يغيبوا عن
التظاهرات وكانوا اقاموا نهايه الشهر
الماضي وقفه احتجاج للتمديد بوجود قوه
الامن في المستشفيات واعتقال وترهيب
زملائهم خلال الاحتجاجات ختمت واشنطن بوست
تقريرها هذا بمقابله مع اطباء في الداخل
الايراني قالوا ان الاطباء لا يختلفون عن
بقيه شرائح المجتمع الايرانيه وانهم
يعانون نفس ما يعانيه الاخرون وهم ايضا في
الوقت ذاته انضموا للاحتجاجات وسيدفعون
الثمن
[تصفيق]